c'est ici que j'ai vécu pendant un an à
la vie tu dois apprendre du jour au
lendemain on t été d'affaires des
valises et rentrer te démerder en fait
[Musique]
c'est à l'heure du bain le seul argent
que vous avez cette époque je faisais de
la com' choses des choses pas forcément
bien du coup bah je vais acheter des
vêtements ici je n'ai mangé ici et j'ai
dormi ici
[Musique]
que j'ai ressenti c'est de l'abandon en
fait parce que l'asie m'ont lâché 2
roland comme plein de jeunes d'ailleurs
ça fait peur je sais pas ce qui peut
arriver demain ici s'il ya des vols il
ya des enfants en tout c'est pas assez
longue c'est la journée un peu ici et
que enfin surtout à 18 ans tu sort ou
qu'on t'a pas forcément a pris toutes
les choses à savoir
en fait t'es pas prêt au monde extérieur
[Musique]
où
ok camarades il faut leur tube devienne
un adulte qui est forte autonomie ce que
tu trouves ton boulot que tu trouve un
logement que tu te débrouilles que tu
payes tes charges etc etc
on a des jeunes qui sont seuls on les a
aidés pendant longtemps et puis tout
d'un coup on va espérer que tout
fonctionne mais déjà ça fonctionne pas
si facilement que ça pour chacun d'entre
nous y compris quand on a la chance
d'avoir une famille dallaire quand on la
chance de pouvoir être aidées par
quelqu'un donc il faut qu'on mesure
collectivement et par exemple qu'on
rende les contrats majeurs obligatoire
que vraiment on accompagne au delà des
18 ans jusqu'à l'autonomie jusqu'à
l'insertion jusqu'à la fin des études
par exemple ce serait vraiment un
investissement très utile pour ces
personnes et pour la société dans son
ensemble
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pouvais rien faire j'ai pas d'argent
en fait c'était de la survie quoi ce que
peu importe ce qu'on peut me dire
aujourd'hui où peu qu'on peut me regarde
et malou dire ouais quoi que ce soit on
fait tant qu'on l'a pas vécu on peut pas
savoir
moi quand j'étais à la rue je ne sais
pas c'est une inversion si on ne savait
pas mon histoire s'ils ne voyaient pas
on voyait pas forcément j'étais à la rue
on ne voyait pas parce que t'as pas
envie de le montrer c'est pas une fierté
[Musique]
ce qu'il faudrait c'est que la compagnie
soit obligatoire jusqu'à maintenant
parce que à 18 ans des enfants ou encore
les blessures on les aura toujours tout
ça tu les feras pas de ta tête tu
d'apprendre à vivre avec mais tu le
fasses rap ou même si ça peut prendre du
temps jeu est avocate
ouais j'aimerais être avocat pouvoir
défendre défendre des personnes ont fait
moi on m'a forcément écouté et
j'aimerais pouvoir écouter de janvier